>> KANNINEN: Hi, I'm Mike Kanninen. I built
the MySpace Application for Android.
>> TOMAS: Hi, I'm Tomas. I built the Shazam
Application for Android.
>> LONGAN: Hi, I'm Casey Longan(ph). I built
the Amazon MP3 Store for Android.
>> TOMAS: So when you use the Shazam Application
after you've tag a sound, you have access
to some other applications. So you can click
on MySpace, you can open the MySpace application,
you can click on Amazon MP3 and you open the
Amazon MP3 application. All of that was really,
really easy to develop, so.
>> KANNINEN: Yeah, for MySpace, we just specified
a UI pattern so that they can send the View
Intent to open a MySpace profile with our
new application the upcoming shows and whatnot.
>> LONGAN: For Amazon MP3, you just create
a new Intent with the explicit package name,
activity name, stuff, a couple key value pairs
in a bundle and fire the Intent.
>> TOMAS: So, using an Android, linking between
applications is very easy using the Intents.
So it was just so straightforward as having
the Intents specification and just using it.